424 الف حساب موثق على تويتر لكن هذا
العدد قد ينخفض كثيرا خلال الاشهر المقبله
قرار ماسك بوضع رسوم مقابل توثيق الحسابات
قبل برفض كبير البعض يرى ان هذه الرسوم
ستجعل من تويتر منصه طبقيه من يملك
العلامه وحده هو من يملك القوه وعرض
القرار الكثير من المشاهير الكاتب
الامريكي ستيفن كينج اعترض على دفع 20
دولارا مقابل الاحتفاظ بالتوفيق وقال انه
مستعد لمغادره المنصه بعدها قرر باسك ان
يخفض القيمه الى ثمانيه دولارات الكسندريا
كورتيز نائبه الكونجرس قالت اتعجب من
ملياردير يحاول الترويجه لفكره ان حريه
التعبير تساوي ثمانيه دولارات رسوم اشتراك
شهريه وبعد يوم من التغريده قالت ان ماسك
حسابها لان كلامها لم يعجب
ايضا شون دارينز مبتكره مسلسل لجريزا
اناتومي كتبت في تغريده مقتضبه غير موافقه
على اي مما يخطط له الى الماسك وداعا
المغنيه الامريكيه سارا باريس كتبت لقد
كان موقع تويتر ممتعا وداعا اراكم في منصه
اخرى